Can you give us the hint of
anything any I don't want to you know get you in trouble with the studio or Marvel, but I mean
maybe could you even just a
Little title. Do we know the title? Could you?
Alright, I think I could probably tell you that I
think it's out there already the the title of the next Avengers movie is
That's out there I can't believe you just told us that's the biggest
That's out there. I don't want to get in trouble. I swear it up
No. All right. It's okay. Yeah, are you sure? Yeah, I'm it that's I I thought it was a spoiler
I mean we all reacted to it. That's I mean, could he could he give us a
another spoiler
I think we giving away too much. So in the final battle Bruce banners in
All right, yeah and and he wakes up and he's like
Turns into the hockey's boss side of this tank
Hey everybody its Charlie so mark ruffalo tried to spoil a whole bunch of stuff about Avengers 4
He said that the title is out there
So I do think that he was actually mouthing something and they believed it and they just nd8
Everybody in the crowd just to be clear though
That's not me bleeping that video that's directly taken from Jimmy Fallon's broadcast
So whatever they were doing the people did that while Mark Ruffalo was speaking
There's a new spider-man ps4 game giveaway
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave a comment on the video
You may have heard the rumor about Avengers annihilation lately
That's like the latest supposed inside rumor Mark Ruffalo saying it's out there. Here's the other thing too
They bleeped him the whole time
He was trying to give away his spoilers
But they put a black bar in front of his mouth when he was speaking about the title then when he did his second
Subsequent spoiler filled rant they didn't cover his mouth at all. They just bleeped him again
Just more evidence that the title like he said was out there
He wasn't lying when he said it's out there
So it's not really a spoiler because people already know it but since it's not Marvel
Officially revealing it on all of their social media accounts
You just have to take it with a grain of salt
And if you haven't read the annihilation storyline
That's all about Annihilus in the annihilation wave trying to destroy all life in the universe in
Thanos sort of playing both sides against each other and him getting killed himself
so it's not like fan OHS verse the Avengers is a much much bigger story and involves a whole bunch of x-men based characters like
Galactus that Marvel doesn't have access to quite yet like they just finish wrapping most people on it
They still haven't finished the deal with Fox
So if annihilation really is the title
Then they're probably just borrowing the themes of that story in that
Because of something that Thanos does say erasing half of all life
It leaves the universe vulnerable to another attack that's going to wipe out all life
during the comic book storyline Annihilus enters our universe the 6-1-6 marvel universe through this bleed between
Universes they call the crunch in the negative zone Drax winds up killing Thanos
there's a whole bunch of double-crosses Galactus reveals that because of what's happening with the annihilation wave in
Santos's actions a couple of ancient gods that he and
Prisoned if the dawn of the universe have been freed and are now threatening everyone
So it's just absolute chaos
In what they might do because they said that Avengers 4 is supposed to have a totally different plot from infinity war
It's not even part to that
Even though Thanos will return it's not just gonna be the Avengers reversing everything that he did it applies
The plot is gonna be much more complex than that
So you could wind up with a scenario where the Avengers do have to get Thanos his help with something
the only
Storyline I could see that would involve fan OHS working with the Avengers on some level if there's some greater threat that threatens all life
Not just half of all life would be something from like Marvel's the end storyline
Which is non-canonical but it involves this really crazy twist with Thanos absorbing the universe and then killing himself
Sacrificing himself so that everyone can live and they reboot everything but that comic book storyline isn't canon to the main comics
So there just could be a situation where we wind up getting rid of Thanos through some slightly different
Means like right now it's all about
Nebula getting revenge on Thanos for everything that he did to her as well as what he did to Kimora
But there really isn't a whole lot of footage from behind the scenes that corroborates anything that happens during the annihilation
Storyline like we're still thinking about this on a pretty simple level with them
Just trying to get everybody that was turned to ash back
You probably heard the rumors about Ronan Hawkeye in the scrolls scrolls were involved during the night elation storyline
But mostly the super scroll the Kree the Nova Corps. It was a very space-based storyline
So obviously they were used quite a bit
fun fact
annihilation conquest was a spinoff of that storyline that served as the
Origin for the new guardians of the galaxy team the served as the basis for the movie team that we've been watching in the MCU
This whole time. So I'm still trying to take this with a grain of salt. I wouldn't call this absolutely confirmed, but it definitely
suggests that that's probably the title because I still think that he was speaking truthfully when he said that the title is out there meaning
That people have figured it out and have been talking about it
It would still fit with what the Russos were teasing the other day because of those two ladders and the two A's that they formed
Like a a it's supposed to be a single subtitle
So it's not going to be multiple words and they've already confirmed that it's not Avengers end game Avengers forever Avengers eternity
Legacy Avengers Assemble or Avengers?
So if it's still two titles in its two A's, they're just only a couple of possibilities for what it could be
Let me know in the comments though
do you think that he was actually mouthing the real title and Marvel is just going to reveal it at a later date or
Marvel but I mean, maybe could you even just a
little
Do we know the title?
Of the next movie
Because Kevin Feige did say that we would learn the title after we got Captain Marvel then they would
Officially start promoting Avengers for like they would for a normal film by the end of the year
So I'm not really expecting any big footage or anything like that to like November or December
But there is a certain cycle for these things
So like the title is something that will probably be learning really really soon from Marvel's official channels
Not just the Mark Ruffalo. Tom Hollands spoiler Bros Channel
There'll be more venom stuff happening tomorrow, uh name the giveaway winner
When I post that there's a couple videos that I'm behind on click here for that new Avengers for Captain America teaser and click here
For my non-spoilery venom review. Thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay. Awesome. I'll see you guys tonight